President Trump is trying to undermine
Obamacare on two fronts the White House
announced last night that it will end
government subsidies for health
insurance that follows a move by the
president to bypass Obamacare rules and
help employers buy cheaper insurance the
government has paid billions to reduce
Obama care costs for low-income
Americans the White House called those
subsidies a bailout of insurance
companies through unlawful payments
Democratic congressional leaders Chuck
Schumer and Nancy Pelosi responded in a
statement saying quote millions of
hard-working American families will
suffer just because President Trump
wants them to Nancy Cordes is on Capitol
Hill and Nancy the president is
following through on a pledge he's made
for a few months now that's right and
each time he's made that threat
Republican leaders here on Capitol Hill
have actually talked him out of it
because they fear that it will drive up
premiums and even lead some insurers to
sue the government but now that they
have failed to pass any kind of
replacement for Obama care it appears
that the administration is taking things
into its own hands I've been saying that
Mike as Nick you'll agree for a long
time let Obamacare fail
president Trump often predicts the law's
demise but now he's taking a much more
active role in nullifying his
predecessors signature achievement will
let Obamacare fail and then the
Democrats are going to come to us and
they're going to say how do we fix it
how do we fix it or how do we come up
with a new plan the administration is
eliminating seven billion dollars in
subsidy payments to insurers that money
helps bring down premiums for more than
six million low-income Americans who are
enrolled on Obama cares individual
market the nonpartisan Congressional
Budget Office has estimated ending these
subsidies will push up premiums by about
20 percent in 2018 and actually add two
hundred billion dollars to the deficit
over ten years we are moving toward
lower costs and more options in the
health care market on Thursday the
president also signed an executive order
to allow employers to buy low-cost
insurance plans across state lines
the plans likely won't be required to
offer certain standard benefits
currently mandated by a
mama care last night in a joint
statement Democratic leaders Nancy
Pelosi and Chuck Schumer called the
elimination of subsidies a spiteful act
of vast pointless sabotage but
Republican House Speaker Paul Ryan
praised the decision saying under our
Constitution the power of the purse
belongs to Congress not the executive
branch congressional Republicans
actually fought these subsidies in court
a couple of years ago and one they
argued that Democrats messed up when
they wrote the Affordable Care Act
because they failed to give Congress the
power to allocate these funds which is
why Charlie the administration has been
having to do it every month or so
Nancy president from tweed this morning
the Democrats Obamacare is imploding
massive subsidy payments to their pet
insurance companies has stopped them
should call me to fix so the question is
where is all this going well
congressional Republicans are now going
to have to decide Charlie whether to
pass some kind of measure to keep these
payments going that's going to look to
some supporters like they are propping
up Obamacare but the alternative is that
they risk getting blamed if insurers
leave the market or sue the government
and so they don't have a great choice
here on their hands and this is
something that they were hoping that the
administration would continue to take
care of until they could figure out some
kind of replacement for Obamacare even
though all their past attempts have
failed Nancy thanks